[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right uh tim callashaw dallas
morning news columnist and
star of espn's around the horn and a guy
who does a great job in breaking down
hype videos that's part of us that's a
side job that he has and tim kind enough
to join us from his busy day
to let us know why dak prescott was not
included in the hype video with the
cowboys oh man this is this is the story
of the year i would think
that uh that didn't happen you know i i
don't know
it certainly doesn't seem like it could
happen by accident like
did we forget somebody we got cd lamb
we got this guy we got that we have
demarcus lawrence
um it so the fact that it couldn't
happen by accident
tells you that it's a little very subtle
shot from the cowboys
they don't they don't have a lot of
ammunition in there
in their quiver uh so that this is their
hey
hey you know we're a team here we're not
all about one player
and uh i don't think it will amount to
anything but it just seems
a little petty on their part but if
you're saying that tim then
jerry jones or his son and son stephen
jones had to
know about this
what did they know and when did they
know yes
you would think but uh what's this
accomplish
nothing nothing it doesn't accomplish
anything it gets people talking about it
and it gets cowboy fans scared oh
they're really not going to sign that oh
what are we going to do for a
quarterback
which you know that just makes them one
of about 22 teams who don't know who
their quarterback is
thanks largely to you the 22nd was added
yesterday
we thought russell wilson was fine the
man of the year and all
and now we find out he's got a camp and
his camp doesn't like it there
way to go uh
it feels like this dak press cut and you
know how it works in the media because
the cowboys get clicks
then we're always talking about cowboys
or aaron rodgers or baker mayfield it's
same stories over and over and over
if dak signs the franchise tag then it
steals this story because they didn't
get a long-term deal or if he signs a
long-term deal then why didn't they do
a franchise tag this is like
this story's not going away no matter
what happens with dak prescott whether
it's a
short-term or long-term deal i i think
if it's a long-term deal it goes away a
little
um if it's if it's a franchise deal no
no question
uh that's 37 million that's 20 percent
of the cap
roughly we don't know the cap figure
that's way too much money
for one player and so they're in that
same kind of
uh ditch that they dug themselves last
year when they wouldn't give them a
four-year deal which still makes no
sense to anybody
i know they put a line in the sand we
didn't know they had who who knew they
outlined about a four-year deal
but they could have gotten a bargain if
they did this when they originally
started
right a long time ago yes a long time
ago yeah remember
his contract realistically uh
they could have they could have redone
him they should have redone him before
zeke and that seems like ages ago they
did
that's a year and a half ago they did
zeke so
yeah now now the one question i would
pose
is you know everything with him has been
compared to winston golf
from the same draft class those two
teams didn't turn out to be happy with
those separate
contracts they did with those players
how much do the cowboys need to pay
attention to that
not that they're the same player but
there's a lot of fluctuation in those
three
uh because there's a lot of second
contracts teams get into and they're
like man
including zeke's by the way yeah he's
like why do we do that that's that's too
much money
yeah i'm with you i i was a vocal critic
of
signing up zeke elliott to a second
contract there but
um you know i'm still trying to figure
out is there any chance that cowboys
move on from dak prescott
i i always have to say there's a chance
with jerry jones there's always a chance
i would i would i think it's very
limited
even though there's some options out
there and you could go say hey we could
go do a deal
and just move on and have more money to
spend elsewhere because we saw last year
this team has a lot of needs there's a
reason they have the 10th pick and it's
not just
dax injury but that chance is less than
10 percent i think dak is your
quarterback this year
yeah has anybody heard from jack
not really uh he had a second surgery
that's been reported that's never great
he had a second surgery in december but
i mean that's a long time for being
from being you know anything for this
year but no he keeps
uh other than doing commercials he keeps
a fairly low profile
any other drama going on in dallas with
the cowboys that we need to be aware of
on this program
well with the cowboys you know the 10th
pick we have that going on
um we have some drama with another owner
in dallas
and whether you want to dive into that
i'll leave it up to you uh you know
with the cowboys it's just well you can
bring up mark cuban mark mark cuban says
that
you know the mavs aren't going to play
the national anthem before
the game and he said he decided this a
while ago
decided in november me being the
intrepid reporter that i am
i've been to two home games i did not
notice
that they were not playing the info uh i
did not pick up on that now
there's no fans of those games so it
would seem kind of odd
although they still do the rest of the
pre-game um
you know you get into a very difficult
area with people
you know media tends to be a little
cynical i've been to thousands of games
the anthem is kind of a boring thing
that you stand there for i realize what
it means
to some people who don't go to a lot of
games uh but we have to recognize what
it means to uh
to players in the nba and uh
it shouldn't be the story that it will
be but since i don't think anybody else
is going to follow his lead i'll be
surprised if they do
then i i suspect it will be an ongoing
story here
how it what's the reaction locally
well i don't think it's this is dallas
texas
so i don't think it's overwhelmingly
positive but i would say this the people
that are upset about it they're not
going to mavericks games anyway
they bailed out on mark cuban in the nba
a long time ago
so that i mean the loud voices on
twitter now as far as the people
themselves
i suspect most of them just want you
know
porzingis to stay healthy and luca to
get his triple doubles
and get into the playoffs they really
can move on from this but
there's gonna be a vocal minority that
doesn't go to games
that we'll hear from for quite a while
are you on around the horn today
i'm taking a day off i'm trying to
restock these shelves behind me as you
see their little baron
you have this nice warm cozy fire i know
perfect man that's so sad like there's
no
awards there's no like there's no means
it means i come with no agenda
wait a minute tim are you at an ikea
no i've had a room that uh
it may have been emptied out somebody
may have left in the last year
oh no oh no
wait did she take did she take stuff
with her
well it would appear no
it's actually things are okay but but
she left your heart she didn't take your
heart
no no no she's still there she just
doesn't reside here
but did you have to did you have to cut
your around the horn victories in half
and give
her half of your around the horn i now
have only 240 wins yeah but that's the
case then woody page would have like
nine victories right oh yeah
his would be all over the world that
would be
that would be a very tenuous thing if we
if we're going
like that i will be back on friday we
didn't talk
certainly about your russell wilson
thing yesterday and real quick
here's what i said about that we think
it's not a big deal but think about this
wilson and the homes
started their careers the same way in
their second and third years as a
starter
two super bowls and one one of them
wilson hasn't gone to the last six
nfc title games what what are we
thinking if mahomes doesn't go
to any of the next six afc title games
something has gone really really wrong
in kansas city
so that's kind of how we should look at
that wilson then what you can say is
is uh mahomes the next tom brady or the
next aaron rodgers
yeah right yeah and uh what do you think
russell was trying to say
tim what do you think russell wilson was
trying to say because he
he doesn't normally say anything yeah he
certainly didn't
say oh i'm not a man i love seattle
that's the farthest thing from my mind
that was not his answer he gave a big
smile and
practically thanked him for asking a
question um
i don't know because it's off it's
certainly that
you know you watch them play he's got
receivers he's got chris carson
they move the ball they score 30 but
they give up 30.
i mean i i think maybe he wants a better
defensive team but it's not like that
team's in shambles
that team's pretty good it just feels
like management has never truly believed
in russell wilson
even though pete gave him a chance when
they they signed matt flynn
from green bay and pete's pete still
after a big free agent signing gave russ
that job so he believed in him then
it's just weird to watch the game plan
sometimes because this is the first year
they sort of let
russ cook because the other years it was
defense and run the football and then
russ helped us out late in the fourth
quarter
and that's when they won and now people
are probably saying
okay russell threw his 600 passes this
year and how do we do
uh you know we need to go back to what
we used to be
so i don't know there's there's not very
many quarterbacks who end up
happy in this league i mean if you think
about it just who won the super bowl
and what he had to do a year ago yeah so
nobody really ends up happy which is
which is kind of a sad state of affairs
yeah he doesn't end his career in
seattle but then
nobody ends their career except for
anymore you know elway did but he
he limped off he couldn't play anymore
nobody else has that ending
yeah flip off in the super bowl hey uh
we'll be watching on
you know what as a show of uh
support i'm not going to watch around
the horn today or tomorrow i'm going to
gear up
come back strong friday yeah i will
thank you tim
all right thank you that's tim calashawn
dallas morning news columnist and star
of around the horn contribute